going to explain the difference between race,
ethnicity and nationality to you guys,
because it seems to be throwing everyone through a loop.
because the other day I asked someone,
what's your ethnicity?
and they said mixed.
when I tell you only to reach into the fire.
I wanted to headbutt them in their chest.
for race is usually the colour of your skin, I e.
I am black even though I'm brown.
racist. stupid.
your ethnicity is your heritage, I e.
I am Jamaican and Guyanese.
yes, that is where my family came from.
now, your nationality is the place you live
or the place you were born in.
is that simple?
I was born in England,
hence I am English.
so if I ask you, what's your ethnicity?
and you tell me I mixed,
everybody's mixed.
so what are you mixed with?
that's the question.